what's up everybody welcome back to my
channel Richard on data if you're new
here my name is Richard and this is the
channel where we talk about data data
science statistics and programming
subscribe for more content just like
this and hit the notification bell so
you never miss an update we're going to
talk about one of the most important
concepts in the statistical modeling and
machine learning world and that's the
distinction between inference and
prediction it's happened to me tons of
times before that people will tell me
they have a project and they want to
incorporate machine learning into it or
they maybe just have some kind of model
they want to build and the purpose for
that model isn't immediately clear
within the first 5 seconds so this is
always one of the absolute first
questions I have is the objective
inferring or explaining some kind of
effect or some predicting future
outcomes now these two terms do come up
in the confidence interval and
hypothesis testing frameworks but we're
gonna focus strictly on modeling here so
I'm going to talk about what each of
these two terms actually mean what
models are typically used for each
objective what the trade-offs are
between them and what some general best
practices usually are for them let's
actually start with prediction because
this one is probably more common in the
modeling world and it's a little bit
simpler so our goal here is quite simply
just to predict future values of some
outcome that is of some dependent
variable just as an example let's take
the real estate world so suppose you're
tasked with building a model or an
algorithm that predicts what homes on
the market are actually worth and in
fact Zillow just recently had a
competition for people to do exactly
this
so you come up with some information
things like a number of bedrooms number
of bathrooms amount of crime in the
neighborhood distance from a body of
water amount of square footage stuff
like that so you end up building a model
and you train it based on historical
data where you have all that information
just based on houses that have sold in
the past
next your measure of success is how
close your predictions gets
- the real home sale values now this is
an instance of prediction and this is
where things like advanced machine
learning techniques deep learning stuff
like that really shines next let's talk
about inference now this one is a little
bit more complex and convoluted to
understand basically with inference
you're trying to infer or explain or
understand how the data exactly affects
the response let's go back to our real
estate example so suppose here
predicting future home prices is not
your goal or at least it's not your
primary goal instead you just want a
solid model that you can trust that
estimates how much the home will go up
in value if you do things like adding a
bathroom or crime goes down just stuff
like that think about something like a
linear regression model and you have
your slope coefficients and let's
suppose you fit a real estate model and
it tells you that for every bedroom you
add holding all things constant the
value of your house will go up by
$30,000 so having that model be reliable
you trust that slope coefficient and
it's variance is as low as possible all
that is key and plus let's face it if I
had a model like that and I trusted it
that means it's time for me to go on
Yelp and find some contractors to work
on my house here's the thing though it
is counterintuitive at first but there's
almost always a trade-off between these
two so the most predictive models are
generally not going to be the ones that
make the most informed and best use of
things like associations and
relationships between your variables
that is the predictive models are not
the most inferential models and
similarly the most inferential models
which do the best job at explaining
variants and how the response varies
with your covariance are not the highest
predictive power models let's say you're
making a linear regression now that's
perfectly interpretable it's probably
not the thing you could do with the
highest predictive capability but from
my experience anyway linear regression
are things which most clients can wrap
their heads around and at least
understand on a basic level just because
linearity is so beautifully simple so in
this case a linear regression model not
the best predictive power but the
inferential capability is fantastic but
then suppose you want to make this
particular model more predictive so you
end up introducing regularization so
depending on if you're doing Ridge
regression or lasso or elastic net you
could end up reducing the values of the
coefficients or just eliminating them
from the model altogether so what you're
doing is you're introducing bias and
you're harming the interpretability and
the overall inferential capability of
the model but you're hopefully reducing
variants and the overall error of the
model and with it you are increasing
your predictive power so again you have
a trade-off less inferential ability
more predictive power next you could try
machine learning methods like k nearest
neighbors decision trees or random
forests these things tend to do pretty
well from a predictive standpoint but
all of a sudden you've totally lost your
interpretability it's not impossible to
explain these things but it's way way
more difficult than it is to explain a
linear model and these are not something
that you're gonna break down to clients
using clean simple mathematical
equations then lastly you have neural
networks and when you have a lot of data
these are basically the gold standard as
far as predictive power is concerned but
people do call these black boxes for a
reason you've lost all explain ability
by the time you get to neural networks
now the question is what is doing these
things actually look like in practice so
I've had my fair share of dealing with
both of these types of problems
probably about equally so although
prediction is probably more common in
the field as a whole and I will say
inference is almost always the more
difficult of the two problems it's not
something that at least in 2020 anyway
we're just going to be able to automate
away using carrot or
I could learn inference requires far
more domain knowledge you'll typically
adjust for confounding variables and
associations between your variables
because fundamentally inference is a
question about causality suppose you've
got some kind of regression model and
then you want to do model selection so
you're probably going to lean in a lot
more to your knowledge of the data and
of the domain as a whole then you are
into things like pseudo R squared or AIC
and this could mean you're keeping
variables in your model because they're
important to the client they're
important to the context of your problem
even if eliminating them could make it
look like your model is going to do
better also as far as dimensionality is
concerned with inference
interpretability is everything so you're
going to have a natural bias towards
simpler and more parsimonious models and
you're probably not going to want to
load your model up with a whole bunch of
different variables and features if you
can absolutely help it with prediction
on the other hand there are tons of
newer methodologies that absolutely
thrive on having lots of data and lots
of features
so in that case dimensionality is a
blessing and not a curse then also as I
talked about with the regularization
example with inference you don't want
bias introduced into the model at all
with prediction though you're probably
willing to tolerate some amount of bias
if it means that you're going to get
substantially less variance and have
less error and a better predictive model
as a whole then suppose you want to
validate the model in the case of
inference things like goodness of fit
tests are going to be more meaningful
but with prediction you're going to want
to optimize some metric like area under
the receiving operating characteristic
curve area under the precision recall
curve root means square error whatever
the case may be optimizing that metric
is your target so summing it all up
these two approaches are very different
what you get out of them is different
the modeling and approach you take is
different but fundamentally the
most important thing is inference and
prediction are answering two very
different questions so whenever you
embark on a new modeling project make
sure you ask that fundamental question
is this an inference problem or is it a
prediction problem so thanks for
watching this video if you found this
helpful
smash the like button also leave a
comment down below and tell me about
what kinds of modeling projects you've
done that fall under either the
inference or the prediction umbrellas so
until next time richer on data